great so um Marin gave her a really
comprehensive overview of the power that
major corporations have in influencing
what it is that we eat but but she was
talking from from a global perspective
but also very much from a u.s.
perspective now Jess you you do a lot of
work in some of the very poorest parts
of the world and I suppose my questions
to you to kick things off is how far do
these major corporations actually have
any influence on people's consumption
patterns there and and if not what are
the other influences on their
consumption yeah I mean I I think that
their influence and reaches vast i work
in northern Kenya on the border of
Somalia you can still buy a coca-cola
it's hard to get healthy food there but
you can buy a coke and i think that the
food environment the place where
consumers engage with this larger food
system is different depending on where
you are in really low income countries
conflict post-conflict countries you
have places that have very limited
choices consumers have very little to
choose from lin dawei knows that very
well in the African context and then you
and that's usually the people that are
going to bed hungry and they're
suffering from seasonal hunger a lot of
stunting as Angus Deaton had talked
about undernutrition but you have this
five billion that's sort of sitting in
the middle they're transitioning from
low to middle-income they're
transitioning away from rural areas
where there's less choice to urban
environments where there's more choice
but there's still vast amounts of
poverty there and that's the group that
we need to think about what are their
choices how do they engage with the food
environment what are their priorities I
work in Baltimore I don't know if any of
you know Baltimore it's a City on its
knees at the moment a lot of racial
tension a lot of inner-city crime we
deal with gun
his incarceration issues like that
people shop at a liquor store behind
bulletproof glass that's your food
environment there's very limited choices
in that food environment so even though
I tend to work more in low income
countries we're seeing pockets of
poverty and limited food environments
even in high-income countries and I
think we have to think about putting
ourselves and those people shoes it's
great to see these statistics what we're
sitting in Stockholm we're in that sort
of the 1,000,000,000 elite category
where we have more power we have more
voice but there's five billion that are
sitting with very limited choices and
not much voice and probably their
priorities are very different they're
not thinking about health and
environment they're thinking about cost
convenience tastes and you see this
everywhere you go to Nepal instant
noodles are the most popular food item
in Nepal because it's cheap it's easy to
cook takes two minutes and it actually
tastes kind of good so we need to start
thinking about the food environment how
the consumers make choices and it's not
always the things that we want consumers
to make it's not always health an
environment that's much lower yeah has
to fit into people's lives and we think
about impacts of issues big drivers like
climate change population pressure
population density is as Angus Deaton
had talked about these are really going
to influence how people make choices
around their diets so I mean you've
talked a lot about the side of
transition so moving from an additional
two different food cultures and I think
Edward II your you are Brazil kind of
epitomizes that dilemma of having to
deal with with this this process of
change and and you in the Health
Ministry have really tried to take on
board this idea that we don't just need
a healthy diet ABC this is what you
should be eating along the kind of us
dietary model but it is actually quite
radical in the way that it talks about
reconfiguring the way we eat do you
to say a bit about those guidelines but
also you know if I get a piece of paper
that tells me how I should be eating
it's not as if I'm going to run off and
do that what what else do you need to do
to make that vision turn into reality
and what are you doing yeah it's
actually a big challenge that not only
in Brazil but most of the world
specially Latin America we have
transition very quickly from
malnutrition to overeating obesity
chronic diseases and that was actually
led to what we're working in terms of
food guidelines which is not making
nutrition of nutrients but making
nutrition of foods and meals and that is
a huge twist because it affects how you
view the food system or food systems
because ultimately our food choices they
bring everything behind it from the
production from the distribution
consumption and even preparation of the
the food so we actually classify the
foods differently based on how much
their process and the soul from net
natural minimally processed foods to
ultra processed foods which we call and
that brings a whole pattern of diets
along with it so speaking from a
government point of view it's a really
huge challenge of how governments can
actually change the system not only in
terms of the health outcomes but also in
terms of the environment and in terms of
social aspects and that's what we're
actually working because from the
governor point of view have to work on
promoting healthy settings of course but
you also have to affect somehow
regulating the system of course and that
comes to the policies of taxation of
subsidizing healthy foods and improving
access to healthy food to have a healthy
environment but also to protect some
specific environments at schools for
instance and other ones but also how to
educate populations there so they can
make the right choices but based on
foods because that's what we found out
them because of the guidelines although
it's radical but it's very close to
reality because it was based on the
actual diet of the population of Brazil
and it could actually be fitted to other
contexts essere if you take an account
what the healthiest part of the
population are consuming so you can make
that in terms of food and try to address
the whole environment in
and that mean so you can work on
production and supply and have the whole
opportunity for consumers to be informed
but also to know where the food comes
from how it's made and make the right
decisions based on all this environment
but so I mean there's a growing emphasis
on the importance of the sort of
socio-economic structures that frame and
influence our consumption patterns and
but I suppose that you could that almost
takes the individual out of the equation
and says the individual has absolutely
no control and what it is they eat and I
think that's probably oversimplifying
the the issue and but if you are going
to take the individual down a stage to
the kind of the genetic and the
biological level let's do do you think
there is any validity in the idea that
we're we're sort of programmed to want
to eat these high-fat high-sugar
high-salt foods that that the food
industry has such an apparently easy job
of selling us and and if if the
corporate might of the food industry
were to reorient ate itself towards
promoting those that diversity of fruits
and vegetables that I know that you're
particularly interested in do you think
there will be any think they'd have any
chance of success well I think you've
touched on different things the industry
certainly makes use of the fact that
humans particularly humans under various
kinds of stresses and that is very much
a situation in modern kinds of settings
do have a very well founded
physiological response which is to get
some high energy you know high-fat food
really quickly and in situations of
chronic severe stress that then is a
recipe for a desire for these kinds of
foods and furthermore it sets up you
know reward patterns in the brain which
almost like classical addiction to drugs
plays into these things so there's a
physiology there but on the other hand
this is not not inevitable because
there's I think education and knowledge
about these kinds of patterns give
people a certain empowerment to realize
what's going on and I'm very struck by
something that Linda is
earlier today which is the fact that
there's only 12 I think 12 main crops
and for animal species that are mainly
eaten and I've come to learn I'm
president of the Salk Institute where
they study plant pathways and I've come
to learn the extraordinary under use we
make of all of the nutrition
nutrient-rich ways plants they just
they've done it all for us naturally and
plants have reduced and credibly diverse
nutritional possibilities we exploit a
very tiny fraction of them very
inadequately for nutritional
optimization and this is not science
fiction this actually very well
understood now that and also
sustainability so why do we eat what we
eat when we know it has such poor issues
in terms of sustainability it's now
quite well understood the pathways in
plants the gene networks since you asked
about genetics but not in plant but the
gene networks in plants that they have
evolved to deal with all the things we
are more worried about in the world
higher temperatures unpredictable water
patterns higher salinity you know
conditions of poorer or extreme light
and so forth this is really not science
fiction so if there was a will to say we
need to actually think about what is it
that's best for Humanity for plants
plants have figured this out humans have
gone a long way to figure this out and
they aren't not using it so i think
there's very interesting things that
once the word gets out plants are really
really consummate chemists they make
their own pesticides really well by the
way we don't need to have external ones
necessarily so I think the science of
what plants do is now with all the
modern technologies of just
understanding plant genetics is now much
better understood they really could
solve these kinds of problems for us and
now it's up to us to say that's what we
want to aspire to because it's all it's
all bare and and so the individual I
think you know when it comes to
collective will and saying you know the
food movements we've heard talked about
earlier
a to say yeah we that's that's the kind
of thing we want to have so maybe our
biology is to say we're very curious as
well and we've found out now what plants
can do and it's much much more than is
being currently used always even
imagined perhaps ten years ago so
there's lots of potential for new plant
breeding and new develops deliver the
sorts of nutrients and nutrition that we
need but the enjoyment resistance to
that's another and resistance but but
the fact is that in so many cultures
across the world the food that is most
valued is meat and there will be a more
detailed session on it today but whether
you're talking about working in in
Somalia where perhaps where meat has a
particular kind of status or in belt
Baltimore in Brazil where me hold in
very high regard it's there it's central
and and how do you um how do you shift
that culture of valuing those sorts of
prime protein what can I yeah that again
biologically speaking it's you know
shift in behavior can happen gradually
and I think many of you know now in a
privileged environment many of my
contemporaries just have shifted away
from meat but it's not like overnight I
think with education and and having you
know suitably satisfying other foods
that's the difference I think meat was
because other foods were not necessarily
so satisfying so I think that you know
outreach education people understanding
that other foods are possible and meat
is not all to be demonized there's ways
you'll care about where you can actually
quite sustainably grow meet in grass-fed
environments which are actually much
more ecologically sustainable than the
current ones that are being used and
that's not for me to talk in detail
about but I think that having great
diversity in our food is to our benefit
and we really need to understand what
optimal nutrition is for adults as well
that's very poorly understood and I
think that's a real challenge to ask
I to as well just do yeah I mean is one
of the grand challenges of as economies
grow there's more appetite to consume
animal source foods and if you're
thinking about the low income context
animal source foods are actually
incredibly important and filling
nutrient gaps for children under 2 it's
very hard to meet that on a local
plant-based diet nutritionists know that
so it's in every right first a family to
want to consume meat particularly in
low-income countries or transitioning
economies we see this in China right
we're seeing this huge appetite for
animal source foods the question is is
you know you have high income countries
like my country the United States where
you have a lot of meat consumption and
how do you get the United States in an
ethical range where you're not becoming
paternalistic in America we're all about
self liberties will become more like
that with our new president elect Mamma
Mia but that's being kind when Johan was
speaking I just my again that climate
change is a hoax is going to be the new
tagline for the United States but anyway
um howdy howdy whose duties and
obligations is it to try to get that
meat consumption down this is incredibly
difficult in some countries you need to
lift it up a bit to try to address some
of the under nutrition that we're seeing
this is really complicated and we get
into issues of who controls our food
environment who controls the food system
and whose roles and responsibilities is
it to hold those accountable this is the
toughest part for us we've got the food
movement that's wonderful but where does
the state come in where does the
government come on where does civil
society come in how do we hold the
private sector accountable how do we
hold citizens accountable when you ask
an American maybe you should eat less
meat
like don't tell me what to eat no I the
question we all have to ask ourselves is
do we have the right to eat wrongly at
this point well that's a good time to
bring in you add water because I've
actually probably not I've actually got
a question to you from the twittersphere
which is a question to Brazil what and
this is the role of the state what is
the evaluation of the soda tax has it
improved health or just the consumption
of coke well to this point Brazil is
still discussing the the food beverage
tax but it has already been implemented
in Mexico for example and I think it's
too short term to have a really impact
on obesity on diabetes but they do have
a reduction in consumption of beverages
but not only coke or any weather but all
sugared beverages and that's very
important and that part of the revenue
that comes from Texas is y'all I
actually used in schools for water
fountains so you are creating mechanisms
to replace that and didactic way it
won't happen the short term but it will
happen but is very important to address
I'd like to switch back to the first the
discussion is the key I think it said to
address food and address that diversity
that we should have in diets and also
synergies because nothing is random even
in foods but I and also in meals it all
comes from a biological evolutionary
context all of this history but also in
terms of meals because we have each
culture that has subsided and has
created these mechanisms of creating
that all of the meals and all the foods
involved in that that brings near the
nourishment that we need so from Africa
to South America to the northern
hemisphere we also address that when you
think of healthy diets so we can work on
supply and demand but in education
walking by hand by hand but having all
the population involved all of the
stakeholders involved from governments
to other institutions but also we're
remembering that there was a very
important international momentum right
now with a decade of nutrition of the UN
so it is a really important moment for
countries to get involved but all of the
stakeholders
the world to actually address nutrition
as a priority for the population in
terms of air and also the stds of course
because it can take environment health
and all of the other aspects in one
picture so we've got 15 seconds to go
and it seems I'm asking a big question
for very little time if if there was one
thing that you felt a government perhaps
not your government can do to foster a
shift towards healthier and more
sustainable diets what would it be one
in turn make healthy foods fun to eat
and not punitive you should do it make
healthy foods affordable I from the
policy by the president think you have
to have the whole set of actions that
that could make it fun make it
affordable accessible and make it part
of the real life and it's not going back
to the past but looking into the future
what we can build right now right well
thank you very much
[Applause]